bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le résumé
des ronds 9 et 10 du match de
championnat du monde dans cette neuvième
partie magnus carlsen avec les blonds à
rejouer le coup c'est 4 au premier coup
et les noirs obtint de cette position au
17e coup 17e coup dans lequel il
préférait échangé le fou pour le
cavalier en faisant vous prend f3 pour
essayer de simplifier la position est
rentrée dans une finale relativement
égale dames et trois échecs et 3h suite
fou contre trois cavaliers pour des cats
vous prend des cadres d'al prend des
call on voit que trois pièces mineurs
ont été échangés les blancs vont
récupérer leurs pions après que trois
dames 5 francs bessette maintenant le
contrôle de la colonne ouverte et très
important après tour à des huit tours
adhère donc nous obtenons une position
avec des fous couleurs opposées les deux
fous ne pourront évidemment jamais se
rencontrer ils sont sur des cases de
couleurs différentes
le fou bessette et le fourbe et six dans
ces cas là on se rapproche de la nulle
sauf que il ya encore les dames sur
l'échiquier
et quand il ya les dames sur l'échiquier
dans des positions avec foucault reposer
le plus important est la protection du
roi vraiment de ici le roi noir est un
peu moins bien protégés étant donné
qu'il ya moins de pions du côté noir
pour défendre le roi noir
c'est pour ça qu'on pensait que dans
cette position les blancs avaient quand
même un avantage intéressant qui pouvait
essayer d'améliorer petit à petit bien
dans l'esprit du style de magnus carlsen
les noirs joueurs dames 7 afin
d'échanger les tours après le coup dams
est l'atout en 18 étant protégé les noms
pour essayer d'échanger une première
tour est de ramener la deuxième
les bleus jouent rh 4h 4 dans l'idée de
fixer la structure des pions noirs en
jouant à chaque c'est pour ça qu'il est
noir djouher g6 qui est une bonne
défense contre ce poste 4 hélas les
blonds joueurs un peu trop rapidement le
coup h5
il aurait dû préparer par exemple on
jouait le coup f3 d'abord pour pouvoir
jouer h5 protégé par le fouet 3 dans ces
cas là peut-être que les noirs auraient
joué h5 eux-mêmes pour bloquer la
poussée du pion mais dans ces cas là les
noirs affaiblissent un tout petit peu
leurs pions et droit en les mettant sur
cases blanches ils pourraient devenir
des cibles pour le fou ou la dame après
le coup blanc h5 les noirs joueurs une
très bonne défense en prenant le pion à
chaque bien joué dans l'idée de l'avancé
en h4 afin d'ouvrir le roi blanc la
colonne sur le roi blanc et donc de
l'affaiblir 1 comme on disait avec les
dames sur l'échiquier en présence de
foot lors opposer la protection de roy
est vraiment essentiel les 20 joueurs
d'al c4 pour protéger la case h4h ans de
prendre avec la dame est donc de
conserver la chaîne de pions stable
devant le roi blanc sorte de château
fort et le très bon coup f5 pour les
noirs qui permet de contrôler la case h
4 avec la dame et les 1,6 après ce coup
les blancs n'ont plus du tout davantage
il ya eu des coups assez rapide après x
j 3 h 4 des échanges de pièces de
reprendre des huit enfants dès 8 g prend
h 4 e g8 el-cheikh 2006
voilà il va y avoir des échanges de
tours et finalement on va se retrouver
dans une position terne
après des échanges de deux tours des
échanges de pions les blancs vont
essayer de continuer cette partie mais
n'auront absolument aucune chance de
gain donc une partie nulle ici
un petit peu gâchée quand même avec le
coût 25 h5 de la part de magnus carcelle
on arrive maintenant dans la 10e partie
où cette fois fabiano caruana avait des
blancs et rejouer évidemment le coup et
4 on se retrouve à nouveau dans une
sicilienne schennikov dans laquelle il
joua toujours le coup sept cavaliers des
cinq mais il a changé en jouant le coût
12 b 4 dans cette partie on se retrouve
au 20e coup après le coup ces sept
les bleus ont investi la lhdaa mais les
noirs ont une attaque sur le petit rock
des blancs avec la belle chaîne de pions
en f4 cinq des six surtout le pion f4
évidemment qui fixe un petit peu les
pièces blanches sur les rangées 2 et 3
on voit le coutour à trois qui a été
jouée par les blancs qui permet de
défendre la troisième rangée dans cette
position les noirs avaient un coût
intéressant qui était difficile à
trouver mais il avait probablement vu
puisqu'il l'a joué au coup d'après
c'était le coup b5 coûterait très
étonnant dans l'idée de chasser le
cavalier si les blancs prennent en
passant le pion b5 les noirs échange les
tours on a trois et enlève du coup un
défenseur sur le roi blanc puisque la
tour on a 3 est très importante donc
peut-être secoue bessin et devait de
jouer à ce moment là il a préféré le
coup aux 4 qui est plus plus logique
puisque on vient menacer avec le pion f4
d'avancé en f3 c'est une menace concrète
puisque et le pion g2 serait cloué par
la dame en g6 du coup le logis croit h1
pour éviter le clouage et c'est
seulement maintenant qu'ils jouent le
coup bessin qui peut être le coup
précédent était meilleur sur le coup b5
les blancs ont eu raison de ne pas
prendre aux passants il n'a joué
cavalier b6 cavaliers pro b 6 fou prend
b6 et dames g5 dans l'idée
d'amener la tour en f 6 puis on à chis
est visé évidemment une attaque sur le
pion h 2 peut-être qu'il aurait été
préférable à la place de d'amener g5 de
jouer beckham d'abord pour attaquer la
tour et éviter de perdre le pion mais
après dan g5 il était difficile avec les
blancs quand même de prendre ce pion
avec le fou même s'ils étaient
probablement de meilleurs coûts fonds
prend b5 et surtout réussissent tout
brugvin c'était la bonne suite de coups
dans l'idée de défendre le purger deux
en ramenant le fou en f1 est aussi en
attaquant le pion à eux quatre avec la
tour une position très compliqué à dans
lesquelles les blancs devait évidemment
réfléchir sur tous les coups possibles
des noirs d'attac et en tout cas c'était
à double tranchant évidemment puisque
les blancs ici prennent un pion
finalement il a pas pris pions il a
peut-être raté un tout petit peu de
chance il a joué le coup j'ai trois des
quatre tours b3 fou
h3 torje un f3 fouet fin voilà les le
fou qui voulait évidemment le fou noir
qui voulait évidemment menacé de devenir
en g2 donc il faut absolument l'échangé
avec le coffret fin fou prend f1 d'un
point f1 pour conserver toujours la
protection sur laquelle j'ai deux sinon
la dame noire pourrait s'infiltrer et du
coup on laisse le pion dessin qui donne
prend des cinq tours b 4 finalement ça
se simplifier un peu après 2006 les
noirs tente de d'avancer leurs pions
centraux avec des cinq tombes et 5 les
blancs veulent essayer d'attaquer ce
pion si jamais ils avancent en d5 food
et 8 pour échanger le fou importants 1
puisqu'il défend à la fois le pion à 5
et le pion f2 et si dans cette position
pour ça et peut-être que les noirs
avaient un petit avantage mais ça n'est
pas évident du tout c'est plus tôt
une position équilibrée mais les blancs
doivent quand même faire attention dames
1 pour fixer un petit peu les pions qui
sont dangereux les pions sans trop
évidemment la dame blanche venir en
trois afin de de protéger aussi ses
pions le plus bref deux et peut-être
aussi le pion v6 qui va apparaître après
fou grand b6 apprend bicis tourabi huit
dames 3 voilà la dame est bien placé
pour tous soutenir chez les blancs dame
ces quatre lames qui s'activent tomber
deux tombés cette v noirs fixe le pion
afin de pouvoir l'attaquer plus
facilement et l'empêché d'avancer parce
qu'il serait quand même à une case de
fer d'armes dont des indes à nos deux
tentatives pour les noirs de rentrer
dans une finale deux tours qui serait
mauvaise pour les blancs les blancs les
raisons de ne pas prendre la d'amoureux
de après d'impro de pions pro2 tour un
tour pro f2 menaçant tout bref un échec
roger un tour bf cette rue menaçante ou
réelle f1 échec est sûre bessette est
vide à mansle et blanc aussi ont un pion
passé les noirs pourraient jouer touré
fut un échec
roy j'ai deux tours prend bessette les
deux tours sont attaqués et surtout
reprendre deux tours prend b2 reprend et
fin des cinq les noirs ont appuyé en
avance dans les finales de tout rayon
des bonnes chances de gagner la partie
après dames 2 évidemment il faut pas
prendre cette dame les blancs ont joué
le bon coup tout re 1 et après d'un
point 3 2 reprend le 3 des 5 h théâtre
dansé 8 ya peut-être encore une petite
pression pour les noirs les blancs
doivent encore jouer de façon précise
après tout à trois roues f7 3h de 3,6 g
4 voilà le roi blanc qui tentent de
revenir dans le jeu puisqu'il était un
petit peu bloquée par la chaîne de pions
noirs dans cette finale maintenant il
semblerait que les blancs doivent tenir
la position après tout ces six tours à 6
les blancs défendre leurs pions et
défendre tous les pions 3e 5,3 g iii et
chis h5 est dans cette position même
plus car le cem qui pensait avoir quand
même un avantage a essayé de jouer
encore pour gagner après le coup droit
des cats qui est finalement pas très
beau coup même si bompas à la finul
quand même il fallait mieux probablement
joué j'ai 6 h congé sisters projet 6 et
tourbe b5 un coût important pour venir
attaquer le pion des 5 et 6 les noirs
jouent h5 les blancs laisse le pion g4
et vont attaquer le pion des 5 avec tour
à à 5 d'oranger cartes et chèques croit
h3 les noirs ne peuvent pas défend le
pion des cinqs avec leur tour en
bessette parce que sinon le pion v6 va
aller à dame et donc les blancs doivent
se tenir là nul ici après le coût 44 3
des 4
le très bon coup tours b 5 qui permet
d'attaquer le pion des 5 mai les noirs
dans l'embarras et finalement le
champion du monde se rend compte que il
doit revenir rapidement protéger ses
pions avec le roi il fait autour des 6
et surtour à quatre échecs et joue le
raisonnable roy e 5 au lieu de roy c3
qui qui devait perdre la partie
rome 5 tours à b4 wahou 6 c 4 les bleus
ont fini par gagner un pion auprès des
princes et quatre tours prend ses quatre
tours déprend bécistes reprend le cadre
échec roi f7 les blancs vont gagner le
pion f3 mais avec trois pions contre 2
ne pourrons pas gagner la partie alors
fabiano caruana n'a pas essayé ils
auraient pu essayer quand même 50 et 1
to f 4 échecs croit g8 et tour au sein
et dans ces cas-là il gardait les deux
tours pour prendre le pion f3 puisqu'il
ya la menace tourbe et 8 échecs ici qui
peut être gênante suivi de tours ff8
avec des menaces de maths sur le roi
après tours b 8 tours pro f 3 tours b 3
tours e36 lennon un échange les tours on
peut prendre avec le pion et créer un
puits
c'est après il ya probablement très peu
de chances de gain il a préféré proposer
nul assez rapidement après tour f 5
échecs au 51e couteau à 6 3 6 3 points
elle 63.3 bref 7,3 g iii est nul dans
cette partie finalement cela arrange de
faire nul ici et il n'y a plus que deux
parties dans ce match et bien merci
d'avoir suivi ce résumé est et je vous
dis à bientôt pour le prochain résumé
des rondes 11 et 12